autre spot légendaire de la réunion mais
pour le canyoning cette fois ci c'est
troublant dans le cirque de salazie
c'est l'un des parcours les plus
appréciés des camionneurs confirmé comme
des débutants 1 km 700 très aquatique
au blanc c'est un des cas les plus
fréquentées avec leurs jeunes tout
simplement parce que
même si les sportifs il est assez facile
d'accès et il est surtout
très très ludique très aquatique avec
beaucoup de toboggans quelques sauts de
petit rappel une tyrolienne c'est un
canyon qui est quand même assez sportif
mais en encadrement qui adapte et quand
même pour un grand public jeune quand
même
c'est pas difficile d'accès il faut être
juste sportifs comme ça qu'elle est une
aquatique il faut apprécier le côté
aquatique bien savoir nager s'immerger
dans l'eau
des toboggans des rappels des sceaux de
la nage troublant c'est aussi fun qu'un
grand parc d'attractions sauf que là
c'est un site 100% naturel un aqualand
creusé dans la roche par l'érosion ou
s'essayer à la glisse en cascade
non
en fait troublant il
se pratique quasi toute l'année sauf en
saison des pluies dès qu'ils allaient
première grosse pluie qui tombe on y
retourne plus jusqu'en fin de saison des
pluies et sinon l'on pratique toute
l'année d'après avec pour les frileux
c'est un petit peu mieux quand même 2 2
avril à mai puis de septembre à au
premières pluies
c'est un canyon débutant au niveau
technique mais il faut avoir des bonnes
conditions physiques
cinquième femme qui est sportif et il
faut surtout savoir bien nager et
s'immerger dans bien apprécié
ici pas de grande difficulté le plus
grand rappel est de 20 mètres le
dénivelé total d'à peine 220 m mais il
faut du temps pour les parcourir ces 200
m la compter cinq heures de descente en
moyenne cinq heures bien engagé donc
avec des passages aux noms poétiques
comme la chenille le tape cul le
vavavoum ou encore le tagada entre
autres des parcours praticables selon le
niveau d'eau bien sûr
en fait c'est des sensations de glisse
et de vitesse on a quand même pas mal de
pâma d'adrénaline
et c'est assez sympa
m
p